ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um den zweiten Teil der
Einführung in den
wissenschaftstransfer ich mache einen
Link zur letzten Sendung oben rechts
rein da ging es um ähnliche Themen heute
knüpfen wir daran an und stellen uns die
Frage nach Medien nach Räumen von Medien
nach dem Verhältnis von Medium und
Wissenschaft und auch vor allem heute im
Zentrum die Frage wie man mit einem
Verlag einer Zeit schft kommuniziert um
dadurch wiederum kommunizieren zu können
dem man etwa einen Beitrag schreibt oder
ein Buch schreibt das nenne ich eine
Metakommunikation eine Kommunikation zum
Zweck einer größeren Kommunikation die
man vorher führen muss und die auch
gelingen oder scheitern kann und davon
hängt sieemich viel ab ob man
erfolgreich ein Medium nutzen kann
gerade auch in der Wissenschaft ich
möchte den Begriff des Raumes hier noch
mal
betonen Kommunikation setzt immer ein
Kommunikationsraum voraus
Kommunikationsräume sind relational sie
bestehen aus verschiedenen Subjekten und
sie werden auch eröffnet durch die Wahl
eines geeigneten Mediums was ein Medium
ist haben wir das letzte Mal schon
besprochen ein Medium ganz allgemein
auch am Wort orientiert vermittelt
Inhalte Informationen zwischen Sender
und Empfänger dieses
senderempfängermodell ist natürlich so
in dies dieser schlichten Form nicht
mehr aktuell gerade auch durch die neuen
Medien das ist der eine Punkt der zweite
Punkt ist der dass die Medien nicht
neutral sind sind Medien immer auch den
Inhalt mitbestimmen also es gibt zwei
Gründe warum dieses klassische
senderempfängermodell nicht mehr
ausreicht um die Komplexität von
Wissenschaftskommunikation zu
beschreiben es gibt verschiedene Modi in
denen
Kommunikationsräume öffnet werden können
physischer Kommunikationsraum ist z.B
ein universitätsraum ein Vortragsraum
ein Saal ein hörsal ein
Tagungsraum virtuell wie jetzt etwa per
Zoom auch gerade dann wenn Leute
miteinander per Zoom kommunizieren aber
auch wenn man das Video dann wie in
diesem Fall hinterher auf eine Online
Plattform stellt auf eine Social Media
Plattform wie z.B Youtube analog und
digit
ganz ähnlich wie physisch und virtuell
auch wenn das nicht genau dasselbe ist
analog Räume sind häufig physische Räume
und digitale Räume sind häufig virtuelle
Räume darauf möchte ich aber nicht näher
eingehen es zeigt nur man kann
verschiedene Arten von Räumen erzeugen
und was auch noch ganz wichtig ist es
bedeutet nicht dass man sich nur auf
einen Raum festlegen muss sondern es
kann durchaus sein man verknüpft
physische mit virtuellen Räumen ja also
Hybride Räumlichkeiten kann man auch
sehr gut nutzen das jetzt natürlich eine
besondere methodologische Reflexion
voraus man kann wissenschaftliche
Kommunikationsräume eröffnen in Form von
Tagungen und Workshops aber auch in Form
von Seminaren die dann etwas kleinere
Räume eröffnen aber auch in Form von
Ausstellungen das betrifft jetzt
vielleicht ihr die Naturwissenschaften
äh oder Posterpräsentation das ist eher
was von Naturwissenschaften wenn man
auch es viel mehr mit Objekten zu tun
hat mit Gegenständen die man anfassen
kann in den Geisteswissenschaften hat
man es nicht so sehr mit
unveränderlichen konstanten Objekten zu
tun sonder da ist alles in Bewegung und
da wird Objektivität immer auf
Subjektivität hin befragt das kann sich
darin zeigen dass man das Objekt
historisiert und fragt wie kam es dazu
in welcher Zeit war das relevant also
wichtiger Trin Geisteswissenschaften
neigen da zu Objektivität zu
hinterfragen und auf subjektive
Bedingungen Hinz untersuchen und das
zieht sich durch alle
Geisteswissenschaften hindurch
Naturwissenschaften haben eher einen
stärkeren objektivitätsbegriff der
unabhängig vom Subjekt ist und das wirkt
sich auch wiederum auf die Form des
kommunikationsraums aus das heißt nicht
für jedes Fach nicht für jeden
Fachbereich ist derselbe
Kommunikationsraum gleichermaßen
geeignet Ausstellungen scheinen ihr in
Richtung von Objekt orientierten
Wissenschaften zu gehen natürlich können
auch Objekte historischen Interesses
sein
ähm das muss man von Fall zu Fall dann
unterscheiden jetzt geht es hier um
Verlage und um die Frage wie man mit
ihnen am besten kommuniziert um dann
auch ein Buch veröffentlichen zu können
hier ist immer wichtig den Hintergrund
von Verlagen im Bewusstsein zu haben
Verlage sind kommerziell interessiert in
der Regel das bedeutet Verlage wollen
immer auch dass die Publikation die sie
dann am Ende auch verantworten ein
großes Leserpublikum erreichen das kann
auch immer sehr sinnvoll sein weil einem
Verlage dann gute Hinweise geben wie man
am besten ein großes Publikum erreicht
Verlage haben unterschiedliche
Schwerpunkte man muss sich hier gut
auskennen gut orientieren und das
bedeutet dass die Wahl des Verlags ein
wichtiger Faktor hinsichtlich der Frage
nach dem gelungenen
wissenschaftstransfer ist was ist das
traditionelle Publikum des Verlags das
muss man sich auch auch immer fragen und
wofür ist der Verlag bekannt oder sogar
renommiert handelt es sich um ein
Fachbuch oder ein Sachbuch dass ich
schreiben möchte ein Fachbuch ist für
ein Fachpublikum gedacht für ein eh
enges Publikum ein Sachbuch hingegen für
ein breites Publikum was eben ein
Sachthema zum Inhalt hat und nicht ein
betristisches hier denkt man natürlich
gleich an die Spiegel bestzellerliste
Sachbuch
oder betristik da gibt's immer diese
zwei Kategorien jetzt wollen wir mal
anhand von K ischen Verlagen am Beispiel
uns mal ein bisschen orientieren das
geht genau für alle anderen Verlage ja
für evangelische Verlage oder für
Verlage die
eher spirituell sind oder um Verlage die
eher philosophisch sind oder Verlage die
eher literarisch sind das gilt für alles
mögliche hier bietet wie immer Wikipedia
ein guten Einstieg hier sieht man
wunderbar aufgelistet alle Verlage die
sich katholisch nennen Aschendorf Verlag
ist z.B sehr sehr bekannt manche andere
weniger und am Beispiel von einigen kann
man das jetzt mal durchgehen der
herderverlag ist sicherlich einer der
wichtigsten theologischen
deutschsprachigen
Verlage und hier sieht man mal dieses
ganze Spektrum was der Verlag alles
anbietet von Kindergarten und Pädagogik
bis hin zu Theologie und Pastoral und
Religion und Spiritualität aber auch
Geschichte und Politik hab hier einen
Bereich wie kommunizieren wir jetzt mit
dem Verlag er schritt wie wir es gerade
getan haben Information auf der Homepage
besorgen und sich informieren was ist
das Verlagsprogramm das verlagspektrum
zweiter Schritt wer ist der zuständige
Verlagslektor für den Bereich der mich
jetzt als Autorin interessiert dritter
Schritt unverbindliche Anfrage besteht
grundsätzliches Interesse an meiner
Publikation und dann kommt der
entscheidende Schritt ein strukturiertes
Expos einreichen über das dann auch
verlagsintern entschieden werden kann
wie sieht ein solches Verlags aus
wichtig kurz und verständlich halten
fünf bis zehn Seiten Bedeutung des
Themas und die Zielgruppe sollte klar
kommuniziert werden das Thema sollte
auch von Lektoren anderer Fachbereiche
in diesem Verlag von Interesse sein es
sollte allgemeinverständlich sein und
man kann auch durchaus an ein
bestehendes Verlagsprogramm anknüpfen
also sagen hier erschien schon ein
ähnliches Buch und ein ähnliches mache
ich das aber noch einen weiteren Aspekt
berücksichtigt soass das Verlagsprogramm
dadurch ab gerundet werden kann auch
eine Vergleichsanalyse kann nicht
schaden worin unterscheidet sich mein
Buch von anderen Büchern nicht nur
dieses Verlag sondern von anderen
Verlagen die eventuell Konkurrenz
darstellen könnten und was für ein
Mehrwert bietet mein Buch gegenüber den
bereits existierenden Büchern auch ein
Zeitplan oder eine ungefähre
umfangsangabe können nicht schaden
wichtig ist hier immer auch dass man
bereit ist mit den Verlags lektorinen
und Lektoren zu kooperieren zu
kommunizieren und auch Anregung
aufzunehmen um vielleicht noch mehr den
Interessen des Verlags entgegenzukommen
das kann häufig auch sehr sehr sinnvoll
sein weil man einen ganz anderen Blick
auf das Thema bekommt nämlich ein
lesepublikumsorientierten Blick und
nicht nur den subjektiven Blick auf das
Thema Zeitschriften Rankings ist ein
weiterer wichtiger Gegenstand der
Wissenschaftskommunikation häufig läuft
die Publikation über Fachverlage das
haben wir jetzt bereits besprochen nicht
nicht selten aber auch vor allem dann
wenn es noch stärker um den
wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt geht in
der Berufsplanung wenn es um Professuren
geht um die man sich bewirbt dann sind
Zeitschriften immer wichtiger vor allem
natürlich in den Naturwissenschaften
aber auch in den Geisteswissenschaften
werden sie immer wichtiger hier gibt's
diesen skimago oder saago Journal
country rank kann man mal googlen und da
gibt es eine sehr gute Suchmaske wo man
den Titel verschiedener Zeitschriften
eingeben kann und dann Rankings ganz
verschiedene Art ausgegeben bekommt
machen wir das mal Beispiel von
Theologie und Philosophie sieht man ein
hindex das ist der zitationsindex der
gibt Auskunft über die zitationsanzahl
ein ganz komplexer Index auf den ich
nicht näher eingehen möchte und dann
sieht man hier noch ein eine andere ein
anderes Ranking und die Null zeigt dass
es jetzt nicht das allerhöchste Ranking
ist wir machen das mal im Vergleich zu
nature dieser ganz bekannten
naturwissenschaftlichen Zeitschrift und
und da stellen wir fest dass der
zitationsfaktor um ein hundertfaches
höher ist und dass auch dieses andere
Ranking zeigt es ist ganz oben im ersten
Quartal also es istusagen die oberste
Ebene der wissenschaftlichen Güte
natürlich muss man solche Rankings immer
auch kritisch hinterfragen und man muss
von Fach zu Fach unterscheiden ob das
Ranking jetzt hier überhaupt
aussagekräftig ist für die
Naturwissenschaften mag das ihrgeld als
für die Geist Wissenschaft hier sieht
man noch mal einen speziellen Index
dieser
simago Seite und da kann man jetzt mal
anhand der theologisch
religionswissenschaftlichen
Zeitschriften mal schauen was die besten
Rankings bekommt und das ist auf jeden
Fall Nummer eins ein internationales
Journal international journal of
practical theology und man sieht auch
hier das zweite ist ein
englischsprachiges Journal das sogar
noch über Open Access Access Option
verfügt das ist immer besonders
attraktiv dieses Symbol hier hatten wir
in der letzten Sitzung gesprochen ist
Open Access dann kommt ein vielleicht
alt eingesessenes deutschsprachiges
Organ was sicherlich eine lange
Tradition hat und so geht das weiter
runter wie gesagt alle Rankings sind mit
Vorsicht zu genießen aber es schadet
nicht sich einen Überblick zu
verschaffen Aufsätze werden häufig
anonym begutachtet double plind Autorin
und Gutachter wissen nicht zueinander
das hat große Vorteile bezüglich
Objektivität wenn es internationale
Zeitschriften sind genießen Sie häufig
auch ein hohes internationales Renommee
es gibt auch Nachteile sehr wenige
Aufsätze werden angenommen häufig
bekommt man Ablehnung das soll ein aber
nicht entmutigen ist bei einer anderen
Zeitschrift noch mal zu versuchen und
die Anregung des Gutachtens mit
aufzunehmen auch das ist natürlich eine
Form von Kommunikation Blogs sind gerade
das Gegenteil hier kann man sehr leicht
publizieren ohne große
Hürden Vorteil ist ist aktuell kostenlos
sehr zeitnah kann man Inhalte
kommunizieren man kann es sehr leicht
vernetzen im digitalen Raum Stichwort
wieder Raum das ist bei gedruckten
Zeitschriften nicht so leicht möglich
ein Kommunikationsraum zu vernetzen
digital geht das vielelleichter häufig
hingegen auf der Seite der Nachteile
findet keine starke Qualitätskontrolle
statt keine Langzeitarchivierung und
auch wissenschaftliche
zitationsmöglichkeiten sind nur begrenzt
durch ein Digital object identifier ich
möchte jetzt hier noch ein paar
theologische Blocks vorstellen anhand
der katholischen e vor allem und hier
sieht man jetzt
was es für Blogs gibt hier noch mal die
kurze Beschreibung das habe ich auf der
Seite des herderverlags gefunden ein
Blog kommt von Weblog ein
Zusammenschluss eine Art Tagebuch den
man führt ein online journal was häufig
auch chronologisch zu regelmäßigen
Zeitpunkten neue Beiträge bringt also
Aktualitätsbezug ist sehr wichtig hier
sieht man eine Auflistung interessanter
theologischer Blogs
ich möchte ein paar vorstellen das ist
katwork.de ähm und das hier das andere
ist auch noch bekannt das ist
feinschwarz theologisches feon es gibt
also eine große Bandbreite von Blogs in
der
Theologie man kann selbst auch sehr
einfach
Blogs erzeugen mittels der Content
Management systematic WordPress
das ist ein Content managementystem das
habe ich jetzt aus Wikipedia diese
Information seit
203%
über 60% aller über Content Management
Systeme organisierter Blogs oder
Homepages werden mit WordPress
realisiert der Vorteil ist es ist
kostenlos und sehr intuitiv zugänglich
Content Management Systeme sind Systeme
die es ein er laauben Inhalte zu
verwalten von digitalen Plattformen von
Publikationsorgan sehr übersichtlich und
sehr intuitiv hier sieht man jetzt ein
solches contentmanagement System das ist
WordPress aus dem sogenannten Backend
das ist die hintere Schal zentrale die
man nicht sieht die im Hintergrund ist
mittels der man dann die Inhalte
publiziert das ist ganz einfach möglich
hier klickt man auf Posts mit zwei drei
Klicks hat man einen neuen Blogbeitrag
erstellt und veröffentlicht wikiis sind
auch noch ein interessantes Content
Management System Wikipedia ist das
bekannteste Beispiel hier geht es
natürlich dann no eine ganz andere Form
von Wissensraum der nicht mehr so sehr
zeitlich orientiert ist Aktualitätsbezug
braucht s hier geht es eher um die
Systematik von etabliertem wissen also
die zeitlogik spielt ja natürlich auch
immer eine große Rolle wir haben jetzt
hier vor allem auf die raumlogik
fokussiert man sieht die
unterschiedliche Bedeutung der Zeit wenn
man auf ein Blog schaut das ist eh
aktualitätsbezogen und auf ein Wiki da
geht's eher um Archivierung und
Vernetzung die nicht so sehr
aktualitätsbezogen ist also auch die
Zeit muss immer als ein wichtiger Faktor
in die Kommunikation gerade auch in die
Wissenschaftskommunikation einbezogen
werden Nachteile häufig auch keine gute
zitationsmöglichkeit ein ein object
identifier fehlt auch häufig so sieht
Wikipedia aus und das war noch ein Wiki
von mir sieht man natürlich ganz klar
die Begriffe stehen im Zentrum nicht so
sehr die aktuelle Aktualität der
Beiträge Twitter jetzt momentan Ex ist
auch noch ein wichtiges
Publikationsmedium was einem Blog gleich
das hat aber noch viel stärker den
öffentlichkeitsfaktor im Spiel die
Vernetzung die Kommentierung auch ein
bisschen die Virulenz die Aktion eine
kostenlose Version erlaubt bis zu 280
Zeichen und eine kostenpflichtige 4000
Zeichen das heißt auch die Kommunikation
der Raum wird eingeschränkt durch die
begrenzte Zeichenanzahl das ist auch
immer wichtig wie viel Information kann
ich überhaupt über dieses Medium
publizieren habe ich von vorne rein
Beschränkungen was ist der Vorteil davon
von Twitter oder jetzt Ex natürlich man
muss auf den Punkt kommen pointierte
Statements die häuf ich auch provozieren
und schitztorms zur Folge haben das
alles wird durch diese diese
Räumlichkeit der Kommunikationsform
schon auch einkalkuliert von vorne rein
wir sehen hier Donald Trump Junior hat
hier einen eigenen äh Kanal
ähm Donald Trump und auch sein Sohn hat
einen Kanal also hier sieht man die
ganzen
Kontakte die ganzen Statistiken es wurde
schon
278 000 mal kommentiert fast 500 Taus
mal geteilt also hier sieht man die
ganzen Optionen der digitalen
Kommunikation die auch immer räumlich zu
verstehen sind weil Teilen bedeutet
vernetzen bedeutet der Raum vergrößert
sich die Likes und hier die
abrufstatistik über 200 Millionen abr
das istind gigantische
Kommunikations Formen die natürlich auf
die Wissenschaft bezogen so nicht immer
möglich sind obwohl auch die Deutsche
Forschungsgemeinschaft einen
Twitterkanal unterhält der natürlich
wesentlich weniger Follower hat das geht
dann so ist dann sehr sehr bescheiden im
kleinerem Rahmen und auch in Österreich
der Austrian Science Fund auch der hat
eine Plattform auf Twitter oder jetzt Ex
und sieht kaum eine
Wissenschaftsorganisation kann darauf
verzichten auch diese Kommunikationswege
zu beschreiten youtube ist auch ein
wichtiger Kanal der ist eine Social
Plattform die aber immer auch mehr
dieses broadcasting beinhaltet man wird
selbst zum eigenen Regisseur
man kann ja sich selbst eigene Kanäle
erstellen ohne große Probleme das ist
mein eigener auf dem auch dieses Video
sich befindet mit über 6000 Abonnenten
und schon über 600 Videos auch das ist
sehr einfach möglich Customizing also
individuelle Einstellung eigene Wahl des
Logos des Titels auch das ist eine sehr
sehr gute Möglichkeit von
Wissenschaftskommunikation die natürlich
immer auch in anderes Zielpublikum
erreicht ich werde gleich noch ein paar
Statistiken hier zeigen hier hatten wir
ein Video von Harald FL das ist so unser
Highlight Video das immerhin schon 600
likes bekommen hat und ungefähr 40.000
Abrufe die altersstatistik meines Kanals
sieht man hier deutlich von diesem
Video es sind häufig 40-Jährige bis
30-Jährige die sich das anschauen in der
überwiegenden Mehrzahl aber auch
Postdocs oder Studierende die ihr
Studium gerade beenden sind da mit dabei
die meisten natürlich aus Deutschland
weil es deutschsprachig ist aber auch
aus Österreich und der Schweiz finden
sich einige hier noch eine interessante
Statistik die den Median also genau die
Mitte der geschauten Zeit angibt von
Youtube Videos und das ist sehr kurz
unter einer Minute 40 Sekunden das heißt
man muss die Videos auch kurz und knapp
halten
sonst verliert man sehr schnell mögliche
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer auch das
wiederum schränkt den Raum den Zeitraum
ein den muss man immer reflektieren
welche Inhalte möchte ich wie
wissenschaftlich in diesem Fall
kommunizieren wenn die
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne doch sehr gering
ist das sollte man alles bedenken ja
wenn man jetzt sein eigenes
Kommunikations und transferprojekt
startet dann gilt es vorher einige
Fragen zu berücksichtigen was ist mein
Ziel das Z Nummer eins das ist das
Wichtigste das sollte man sich am besten
selbst mal aufschreiben vielleicht sich
auch mal mit anderen Menschen darüber
unterhalten welche Inhalte möchte ich
vermitteln Kontext jetzt hier z.B die
Wissenschaft was ist mein Publikum meine
Zielgruppe danach muss ich auch die Art
und Weise der Darstellung der Inhalte
anpassen wenn es ein Publikum ist was
sich nicht so gut auskennt was nicht ein
Fachpublikum ist dann muss ich die
Inhalte anders vermitteln vielleicht
muss ich dazu auch ein anderes Medium
wählen vielleicht genügt dazu ein
Blogbeitrag welches Medium ist für meine
Zielgruppe geeignet natürlich auch immer
unter dem Gesichtspunkt des Themas das
bedeutet in welchem Raum und in welcher
Zeitform soll die Kommunikation
stattfinden in einer Minute 30 Sekunden
wie idealerweise auf Youtube oder in
Form eines Blogbeitrags eines
twitterbeitrags mit 200 Zeichen das muss
man individuell selbst entscheiden das
war ein kurzer Einblick in die
Wissenschaftskommunikation wir setzen
dann die Reihe fort im neuen Jahr wenn
es um das Thema forschungsmanagement
geht ich bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit